madame la ministre donc en fin de
semaine dernière près de cinquante mille
lycéens ont fait le feraient les frais
d'un bug de parcours sup à la mise en
place de ce nouveau dispositif
nombreuses étaient les personnes à
s'émouvoir de l'impact psychologique des
situations liées à l' attente de
réponses et de vérification des
classements mais qui aurait pu prévoir
un tel ascenseur émotionnel pour ces
jeunes gens un mois du début des
épreuves du baccalauréat
comment en est on arrivé là moins de
deux ans après le fiasco d'apb les
témoignages de lycéens issus des
familles inquiètes et affluent et en
filigrane se dessine à nouveau la grande
interrogation de ceux ci à propos des
algorithmes et du manque de transparence
de la plateforme vous nous expliquer que
400 formations auraient fait des erreurs
humaines mais comment autant de
formations monte lui aussi ainsi faire
tant d'erreurs
n'y at il pas eu vraiment aucune aucune
instruction de vos services ou à tout le
moins les directives données nous tel
pas pêché par manque de clarté dans les
deux cas madame la ministre il est de
votre responsabilité
nous sommes nombreux à nous interroger à
nous demander si les formations non
patissia m'encourager à gonfler
excessivement leur taux de
surréservations pour raccourcir les
délais d'attentes pour les candidats et
accélérer la fameuse convergence
madame la ministre le sujet grave la
représentation nationale vous à vous
écouter pour entendre en sorte que les
908 candidats ce qui ce parcours sur
leurs familles attendent des réponses
claires et précises
j'aurai la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche et de
l'innovation blindes vidal vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur jacques grosperrin
vous avez raison lui rappeler les
erreurs qui ont été commises par les
formations sont inacceptables et elles
ont suscité beaucoup de faux espoirs
chez de nombreux candidats mais au-delà
de ça sur les 2 % de deux formations qui
ont commis ces erreurs
ce que je dois dire c'est que à la fois
le service central qui gère parcours
super qui a vu apparaître ces erreurs
comme les responsables de ces formations
ont souhaité réagir immédiatement de
façon à ce que l'ensemble des neuf cent
mille candidats puissent avec quelques
heures de retard
et bien obtenir des propositions dans un
contexte qui avait été totalement
corrigé pendant la nuit et c'est
l'accompagnement humain qui a aussi été
mis en place par les rectorats par les
responsables de ces formations par les
professeurs principaux et les proviseurs
des lycées qui accueillent ces lycéens
que je voudrais saluer aujourd'hui ce à
quoi vous faites référence et c'est ce
que j'ai eu l'occasion d'expliquer tout
à l'heure n'a rien à voir avec ce
phénomène d'erreurs qui s'est produit il
est normal que lorsqu'une formation à 30
places elle puisse appeler une
quarantaine de candidats car nous le
savons tous tous ces candidats ne se
présenteront pas à la rentrée et c'est
d'ailleurs un nombre de places qui du
coup ne peuvent pas être offerts à
l'ensemble des candidats
ça c'est ce que l'on appelle
effectivement un taux d'appel supérieure
de 30% à la norme mais les erreurs que
nous avons constatée et que le service
parcours super ont constaté était d'une
tout autre ampleur
ce sont des bts à 12 places qui ont
appelé plus de 300 candidats ce sont des
classes préparatoires à 30 places qui
ont appelé plus de 600 candidats ils ont
simplement interverti le chiffre en
d'appel avec le chiffre de la liste
d'attentes et c'est ce sujet là que j'ai
demandé à l'inspection générale de
vérifier de façon à ce que nous
puissions mettre en place des contrôles
qui évite que ces erreurs humaines se
reproduise jour merci monsieur
grosperrin cinquante mille candidats
affectés par le bug sur les quelques 900
mille inscrits c'est trop 400 formations
qui se sont trompés alors que l'année
précédente aucune s'est trompé donc ça
nous interpelle est ce que cette année
c'était pas c'est clair ou mal
accompagné si erreurs j'entends bien
votre empathie aujourd'hui vos excuses
mais j'crois que ça aurait été important
aussi que les lycéens les 90 en aussi et
puis vous appeler madame la ministre sur
le fait que les boursiers actuellement
ou une réponse positive alors qu'il ya
des étudiants d
des lycéens très brillant qui n'ont
aucune résultats et ça les interroge en
tout cas si les interpellent au sein de
la même classe et à l'heure où justement
nous venons de voter avec le ministre
jean michel benquet l'école de la
confiance il nous faut retrouver cette
transparence de ce parcours su que je
vous remercie